[Musique]
la première chose que vous feriez est de télécharger
l'application de livraisons de vaisseaux spatiaux, puis de
charger vos informations client afin que
vous soyez configuré une fois que vous avez cette configuration,
cela vous indique si vous êtes à portée
des livraisons de robots en ce moment  si vous
êtes à portée, vous passez simplement
votre commande dans l'
inventaire disponible en ligne, puis vous passez à la
caisse, puis la commande vous parvient
bien, nous recevons les commandes par téléphone,
nous remplissons donc les sacs dans la boutique, puis
le vaisseau spatial  les répartiteurs chargent les robots
et expédient J'ai utilisé la livraison Peapod
qui est géante ainsi que les
livraisons Amazon pendant une longue période maintenant,
il est très très difficile de les
programmer pour remplir beaucoup de restaurants ou de
livrer des produits maintenant, c'est quand vous
pensez que nous nous  avons un petit groupe de
personnes qui ont continué avec nous et
nous essayons tous de rester en sécurité nous portons tous des
masques et des gants et nous désinfectons constamment
je veux dire que nous savons qu'il y a toujours un risque
parce que nous sortons toujours tu sais  w à nos
familles à nos immeubles à appartements ou
quoi que ce soit donc il y a toujours des risques mais c'est
un peu c'est minimisé en ne laissant pas
le client
vous